So, um, you want to talk about Vegas or what happened? Uh, yeah,
I like the story. I like how you think that I set you up for district because,
okay. So Bobby calls me in the middle of the day. Uh, I,
I remember this very specifically, cause I just got done shooting,
like a music video in Venice and he calls me and he's like, man,
what are you doing tomorrow? I was like, uh, I dunno,
I got like a show around here locally in LA, but that's about it. What's up.
He goes, you want to go to Vegas? I go.
What? Because you don't want to go to Vegas with Papa.
Yeah. The way he, yeah. And I was like, like for like, for like,
for a show. Yeah. Yeah.
Daddy's got a private corporate gig and I need you to open for me. Yeah.
I was like, okay, great. And he goes, all right, Mimi,
tomorrow my place pick me up.
And then we're going to go rent a car and then we'll drive to Vegas. I was like,
okay, cool. So we go to the rental place,
he fills out all the paperwork and we're looking at all the cars.
And then he like tosses me keys, like an eighties movie.
I catch him and he's like, that's us over there. Yeah.
And then I can drive the whole way. Yeah. Yeah.
You're on your iPad the whole time. It's beautiful. Yeah. And uh,
it was a brand new Dodge challenger and
it was like really faster car than we needed,
like by any means. Yeah. And we go to Vegas and uh, we have a good time. Like,
Bobby's take it to dinner, dude. I mean, I remember the picture of that steak.
Steak was ridiculous because they were a fan of Bobby and they're like,
I'm going to get you prime cut. And ju we couldn't even finish the meat. Yeah.
Yeah. And I being, you know, his poor opener, I'm like,
can I take some of this to go? Bobby will not let you take it. Yeah.
The amount of Y Y though, you're like, I paid for it.
That's nine because people,
I tell that story sometimes and people don't have to believe me the amount of
meals that,
that I wanted to take with Bobby crazy.
But he just leave it, but then you go, you really want that.
You really want that dude. He just take some money, just go get a new meal,
get a new meal. I know I'm such a gross person hearing it,
hearing it though. Yeah. Right. It makes me feel like, why do I behave that way?
So, um, and this is good. This is a good thing. So then what happens every time?
Like, just like on the way we get some meals and stuff like that. And uh,
I remember at the check-in counter,
we had a room like that at this amazing suite at the wind. Yeah.
Yeah. Like it was, it was like this amazing spread.
I'd never seen a hotel like this in my life. I'm from, I'm from Kansas.
I'm like, I'm in Vegas right now. I'm with Bobby. Like, this is crazy. And uh,
we check in at the counter and uh, he's like, Hey man, uh,
reservation for Bobby Lee. And uh, he says, Oh, welcome Mr. Lee. And uh,
he looked at the guy at the counter. He's like, uh, we're going to,
we're going to go each other in that room
As a joke though, as a joke, as a joke, you know, Bobby does that. Yeah, yeah.
That thing. Yeah. Yeah. And, uh, and,
and I like go into it. I go along with it. Cause I yes. And everything like,
yeah, man, I, I, I'm going to suck his Dick and Bobby didn't like that.
I played along,
Bobby likes to be the weirdest person in the room.
It's mad when somebody gets really upset. I do. He's like, Hey,
just a joke. He's like, yeah, I'm going to his butt. Like, like he had the.
[Inaudible].
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So we checked into this room and uh, I tell Bobby, I'm like,
Oh, can we take, can we take some, some promo photos? And he's like, yeah, sure.
And, uh,
and so he has his shirt off and I started to take my shirt off and he goes,
Whoa, what are you.
Doing?
I was, I was going to join in with you, you know, promo photo. Yeah. Now man,
that's me. You're the opener. Keep your shirt on. He's like,
he's very much likes to put me in my place. Like I like our entire friendship.
I feel bad. It's okay. But finish the story.
So we go to this gig later in the evening and it's for
an all male crowd, literally at the top of the show,
it's, it's a game for Bobby comes down. Men's like, it's, uh,
it's a billionaire men's club. And it's like, you know,
a bunch of businessmen and millionaires. Right.
And I don't know why you would think that they would hire Bert Kreischer or
somebody of that elk. Right. But for some reason they wanted me.
And so we go into this and also in this room, right.
It's not just a showroom. It's, it's a gigantic,
like a warehouse looking like a place. Right.
Like it's a convention ballroom ballroom. Right. Huge ballroom.
And then it's like,
the other half of the ballroom is curtain off for an auction.
So there's like sports cars in there and like memorabilia, you know what I mean?
Yeah. And people are, you know, in, in,
in the place where we're performing, people are there, but they're also,
people are outbidding and walking around in this other area
and we're supposed to perform or just the front part of the,
in this environment is like performing in front of a cafeteria. Yeah. Right.
Because it was, there was no show, almost what it felt like.
It felt like a nightmare. It was, it was one of the hardest gigs I've had.
I've never seen anybody
bomb as bad as your Maya. I mean,
I've seen thousands of shows. Right.
But here's what loved about it. It's like, you know, when you bought,
like I've seen openers bomb and cry. Ooh. Or they,
they start off strong, but delete the crowd. You know what I mean?
Wither them down into nothing. Right. And when I see that happening, I feel sad.
All right. But what would I see what Jeremiah did? Right.
It makes me proud, like a proud parent, what this guy got.
He goes up there and people, there are guys standing up.
With red.
Face veins on their faces. Right. This is a hundred percent true. Yeah.
A hundred percent true.
You suck, get off, get off.
Oh my God. Screaming,
screaming now worried about neighbors that,
but that's literally,
literally that's in the first 40 seconds. Oh.
Right. And I'm in the back, like it through a curtain, looking at them. Right.
And when I'm hearing get off, Jeremiah is onstage,
upside down with a stool or something. Right.
And oppose pole. Right.
And he's doing some sort of
some sort of bit. Right.
He doesn't meaning thousands. He does not care. Right. He does. How much?
Three minutes. No mom said, you said,
this is what you said right before I went off. Yeah,
because you had to do 40 minutes for this call.
Like you do 40 minutes and you go, you go, all right.
And easy to do, uh, seven minutes. And if you want to make daddy real happy,
do more like 10. All right. Yeah. Okay.
And before I went out there, they just done a raffle. They just on a raffle.
And then the guy, the host, he gets handed a card and he goes,
Oh, I guess, I guess the,
the act brought an opener.
Yeah.
This is my intro. I guess the act an opener. Yeah. Uh,
please welcome. Jeremiah. Doesn't even say my name is Jeremiah,
Jeremiah. And I walk out nobody claps,
nobody class because they want to see Bobby.
So what Bobby knew was going to happen is that I was going to be the
sacrificial lamb for that gig too.
No, you didn't. No, you didn't. I not as hard as you.
Bobby, you're doing that thing. You're doing that thing. No, no, no.
He did. He crushed.
Exactly.
But he told me, but, but to preface this on the, on the way to Vegas,
the entire time Bobby is telling me.
Bond and I love that you're going to buy.
I haven't done that before my first time doing steaks,
you actually did on this podcast for three weeks and promote it. Yeah. So,
and I was like, no, I'm not. No, I'm not. You're you're like, you'll see.
You'll see. And then it happened.
The only laugh I heard the entire time was Bobby dying. Laughs.
Backstage just cackling.
Cause it was so he thought it was so funny to see what was happening.
Just the absolute nothing that I was getting from the crowd. I know,
but I wasn't laughing at the, because of your failing.
I was laughing at the fact that you're seeing two different things at the same
time. Of course you're seeing hatred, like literally like, you know,
um, imagine like, um, AOC going to a Trump rally. Yeah.
That's what it felt like. Yeah. Like just the wrong person at the wrong time.
Right. And then AOC committing right to a speech.
Right. And finishing it like w I have a 10 minute speech.
I made a Trump rally and I'm going to finish it now.
AOC saying good night. And then Trump walking out,
kicking her in the.
And saying, yeah,
that was Bobby that night after that Trump,
he destroyed. And literally.
Like, you know, they're cutting them, the check and stuff. And they're like,
wow, that's amazing. Everybody's coming up to him, shaking his hand,
one pictures. And I'm just standing there,
like looking for anything the entire time, just looking for any reassurance.
And uh, the Booker kept looking at me and going, yeah, kid, good luck. Uh,
yeah. But then Bobby, he knew what had happened.
He took me out to like the nicest steak dinner afterwards and reward me.
He's like, dude, you did exactly why I brought you here.
You did exactly what I wanted you to. I'm going to tell you something.
All right. If he hadn't gone, gone up before me and done that,
I would have struggled for 15 minutes. Of course. Right. Yeah. I knew.
So I needed a kid, right. That was going to commit to it. Right.
Was going to know he was going to fail. Right.
And set me up and I'm going to say this right now. It sounds cruel.
But I had been that guy, of course. Right.
Jay Moore did it to me at USC. Right.
We had a daytime show. Right. It was show supposed to start at five. Right.
And I was supposed to do 15 minutes, but I'm, I'm,
I'm in my 15 minutes. And, and I was like, I'm about to wrap up,
but the sun was still up and Jay Moore goes,
you're not getting off stage until the sun is your mean
gone till it sets until it's black. Oh, geez.
Right. And I remember being up there for an hour.
Yeah. Eating it.
Running around. I did everything. I could,
every trick that I had in the running around.
I roll, clap, sing a song. I was doing.
Everything right. And I so bad. And I got upstaged so angry off state, so angry.
And then Jay went up, you know, I mean, everyone cheered, he killed it.
And I just remember just being in a ball of anger in the bag.
But then in retrospect, I go, I thought, you know, that's just the best,
you know, comedy experience that you can have because it's like,
you're learning to perform, right.
Like when you're on the tonight show and you're bombing, right.
If you're,
if you've condensed conditioned yourself to pretend that you're doing well in a
hostile environment, right.
People on the camera watching it are going to go, Oh, he's doing fine. Right.
It's if you let the audience affect you right. Then you're dead.
And that's why I think the comedy store store is so important because it's such
a tough room. Right? Yeah. We were able to learn how to,
that's why when you play the comedy store and then you go to a place like the
ice house, it's easy. It's, it's like,
you're killing it. Right. But, um, I think that, you know,
putting young comics in those kinds of environments is a good thing.
In the beginning of all this, you said that in Vegas, he you.
So it was the other way around. I did him.
I you. Yeah, dude, I you. And I apologize. It's okay, man.
But look at you now. I know,
but no, it's not that we freaking made it, dude.
I want to say something. Okay. When I watch you, when I watch, um,
Tony Hinchcliffe shell, right. What's it killed Tony. Yeah. Right.
It's and I watch you improvise into different characters and, and do your thing.
I think I literally always think to myself. Wow. That guy is so funny.
I really do.
We're taking a really quick break to share one of our favorite sponsors. Yeah.
[Inaudible] if you need it, you're going to need it.
[inaudible] if you're a man you're to whoop.